yes and one welcome to this announcement
video this Wednesday today yeah we got a
double feature again I have a two shows
on shares 24 first one will be been
tablets in German shred splits and it is
called so we have a German language show
this will start to see the counter here
at six in the evening Central European
charm 19 minutes and then two hours
later and we can you see different
splits two hours later oops two hours
later we have the regular bench of this
in English language so if you if you
like you can get a full dose for three
hours maybe a little bit more with the
typical extra time I two of ya bent on
this action first German language than
English language I'll be on this evening
and English is on its eight central
european time in the evening so yeah
make sure to tune in just go to chest to
any for calm and go from there it's easy
to do you can participate in the chest
by the way also with a non premium
account to play me you need to have a
premium account not just 24 yeah thanks
for watching the announcement hope
you'll be on this evening bye bye